[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
are going to be talking about universe 6
so yeah it really happened universe 6
the twin of universe 7 and the one other
universe other than 7 that we know the
most about has just been eliminated from
the tournament of power and erased from
existence episode 118 was really a
heartbreaker and we will be talking
about exactly what happened right here
in this video we will also be discussing
whether universe 6 will really stay
erased or whether it will somehow be
revived and I will go on to discuss some
possible ways that universe 6 or at
least some of the characters from
universe 6 could be brought back in the
future even though we could definitely
see this coming especially after hit and
kefla were eliminated this still feels
unreal and I think that the reason it
feels so unreal is that we have gotten
to know a lot of these characters from
universe 6 really well and we have
become attached to some of them
personally I think hit is extremely cool
he's one of my favorite characters in
Dragon Ball super and I loved seeing him
put up a real fight against Gina I will
definitely miss hit a lot and another
thing that I really liked was the
relationship between Vegeta and Kaba and
how Kaiba looks up to Aegina as his
mentor and how Vegeta slowly warms up to
Kaaba so I will definitely miss him as
well and there are of course kale and
cauliflower general opinion on them is
split because some people disliked them
because of how fast they were able to
raise their power levels and reach new
Super Saiyan forms while others do like
the idea of having strong female Saiyans
playing an important role in the series
personally I do have my issue with how
fast Kalin Khalifa have gotten stronger
but I also did really enjoyed the fight
between kefla and Goku I thought it was
one of the best fight of the tournament
so far so in that sense kefla will be
missed and by the way I made a whole
video in which I used some real-world
examples to explain why Kalin Khalifa
were able to increase their
powers sold quickly so if that's
something you're interested in I will
leave a link in the description also if
you enjoy the Dragon Ball super content
on this channel be sure to leave a like
to let me know and if you're new don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification belly yes I really like hit
starting next Saturday we are planning
to watch the new episodes of Dragon Ball
super as they come out live on our
twitch channel we don't do reactions
here on YouTube but we will be hanging
out on Twitch and chatting if you want
to share the epicness alive we will have
a timer on so you can follow the episode
along with us and if you want to hang
out and chat with us live
follow us on twitch twitch TV slash
anime uproar link will also be in the
description whether you loved or hated
them over the course of the series we
have gotten used to the characters from
universe 6 and it really does seem harsh
for them to have all been erased
out of existence like this so this leads
us to the big question is universe 6
gone forever
or will our heroes from universe 7 find
a way to bring them back Vegeta told
cabba
that a few number 6 lost in the
tournament that he would wish them back
into existence using the super Dragon
Balls although we have never seen Super
Shenron actually bring back an entire
universe so we don't technically know if
it's even possible since his power is
described as unlimited as long as there
is only one wish we can assume that
wishing universe 6 back with the super
Dragon Balls is a real possibility
in fact in Dragon Ball Z the Dragon
Balls were used to bring back everyone
who was killed by Frieza and his forces
on Namek and also everyone who was
killed by cell and the androids on earth
so if super Shenron can revive entire
universes it may be possible for Goku or
Vegeta or someone else to wish back
everyone who was erased by Zeno during
the tournament thereby bringing back all
of the universes and all of the life
inside of them
however we are then left with the
question of what Zeno and the grand
priests would think of such a wish
would they honor it because the winner
deserves to wish for whatever he wants
or do they
get angry that the winner decided to
undo everything that zento had done this
is a really interesting question and I'm
extremely curious to see how something
like this would turn out another
possibility is that Shenron can't
actually bring back an entire universe
but we know from episode 41 that he can
revive entire planets because beerus
successfully wished for the earth of
universe 6 to be restored so perhaps a
planet or planets from universe 6 could
be revived inside of universe 7 I don't
know how this would work exactly since
the universe 16 wasn't even on their
home planets when they were erased so if
let's say Vegeta wishes planets addala
back from universe 6 to be revived
inside universe 7 we don't actually know
if Kaba Kalifa and kale will even be
saved by that for this reason I don't
think that this possibility is likely as
it wouldn't save the countless
inhabitants of universe 6 that would
stay erased and even some of the main
characters that we know from universe 6
would likely not even be saved in this
scenario a third option is that super
Shenron won't even need to revive
universe 6 because zento will bring
universe 6 back along with all of the
other universes if the theory that I
outlined in my what if the grand priest
is actually good video is true then the
grand priest is using the Tournament of
power to teach Zeno an important lesson
and this lesson is that mortals actually
have value and in xenos case they have
value because they can be very
entertaining as a creature who exists on
a higher plane of existence Zeno is
currently incapable of relating to
mortals and fully understanding what he
is doing to them when he erases a
universe but one of xenos biggest
problems is his boredom and he always
wants to just play and have fun if we
look at both Zeno and future's anno
during the tournament of power we can
see just how much fun they are having
watching the tournament they are having
a blast and absolutely loving all of the
different fights techniques
transformations and so on
so once the tournament ends and the
seven losing universes
are erased Xena will realize that he can
never watch another tournament like this
one again because most of the
participants are gone with only five
universes left all together any future
tournament would have less fighters less
unique techniques less interesting
characters and so on at this point the
grand priest may approach Sano and
explain to him that if he wants to
continue being entertained by all these
mortals he has to bring the universes
back and then perhaps he can organize a
regular tournament in the future for
each universe to showcase their best
fighters every few years or so like a
universe Olympic Games this would be an
interesting twist and it would also open
up the possibility for more major
tournament arcs in the future depending
on how long Dragonball super goes on for
the final option is that universe six is
really gone forever and that it won't be
brought back and while I have to admit
that this is a possibility
I find this unlikely the simple reason
for this is that the Dragon Ball
franchise is famous for bringing
characters back to life including a
large amount of characters at the same
time like everyone killed by Frieza or
everyone killed by cell and so on so
there is definitely precedent for a
large group of people being brought back
to life and even though this situation
with entire universes being erased is
clearly different I still think the
Dragon Ball super will find some way to
bring universe 6 back that's just my gut
feeling
at this point but let me know what you
guys think you know that I read the
comments so give me your thoughts and
ideas down below will the universe 6 be
revived and if so how will it happen
also which characters from universe 6
are you going to miss the most let me
know who your favorite and least
favorite universe 6 characters are if
you're looking for more Dragon Ball
super content to watch we have a full
playlist now right here on the channel
including videos about why Frieza might
end up being the MVP for universe 7
during the tournament and what secret
power Vegeta might be hiding in the
tournament of power links are in the
description if
want to support the channel and get cool
anime merch like your girl calls me
senpai and keep calm and ultra instinct
you can check out our merch store link
in the description if you enjoy these
videos and want to see more be sure to
leave a like to let me know and if you
are new to the channel don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
I also want to give a big thank you to
all of our anime upper patrons for
supporting the channel so that we can
keep doing what we do including
Christian floor Cubano
third strike Sinead oh the one and only
Gilgamesh and original link also big
thank you to all of our former patrons
and if you'd like to consider supporting
the channel on patreon link is in the
description feel free to let me know
what types of videos you wanna see here
on the channel in the future we got
plenty more Dragon Ball super content on
the way here at anime up or we also make
videos about other anime including
attack on Titan my hero academia Code
Geass and more so if you're a fan of any
of those feel free to check out our
playlists as always thank you so much
for watching and until next time see us
space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]